retour en france que sont les gm de l
des grenades assourdissantes et
lacrymogènes qui remplacent désormais
les glyphes 4 est des armes de force
intermédiaire responsable de graves
blessures lors d'opérations de maintien
de l'ordre notamment pendant les
manifestations de gilet jaune alors pour
faire le point sur ces nouveaux outils
avec nous sur ce plateau antoine boitel
journalistes rt france spécialisé en
questions policière dont jour bonjour la
neige alors antoine vous avez mené une
enquête sur cgm de l après que trois
journalistes de rtl france ont
légèrement été blessées à paris le 28
janvier dernier lors d'une manifestation
de pompiers contre la réforme des
retraites
qu'avez vous découvert à ce que cette
arme est elle plus ou moins dangereuses
que l église
4 alors ce qu'on a découvert c'est que
premièrement l'armée au moins aussi
dangereuse que la griffe 4 g m2 elle est
censée venir substituer se substituer à
la guille f 4 ainsi que l'annoncé
christophe castaner le 26 janvier c'est
à dire deux jours avant cette opération
de maintien de l'ordre auquel 3 nos
journalistes ont été blessés
comme vous l'avez rappelé ce qui nous a
intéressés en fait c'était que cette
arme est présenté comme un outil de
force intermédiaire qui va
qui va éviter les éclats les éclats
vulnérant tel que le décrit le fabricant
et salua le cettex or il s'avérait qu'il
ya bien des éclats en tout cas il ya des
morceaux de grenade qui sont venues se
ficher dans corps de certains
journalistes
heureusement pas les nôtres parmi les
trois journées ski ont été blessées
l'une a été fortement perturbée par le
gaz l'effet de gaz lacrymogènes cs est
donc au départ on ne savait pas trop ce
qu'elle avait elle a eu un problème aux
yeux du coup elle a fait une petite
infection à l'oeil un autre donc ça
c'est un effet prévu de la grenade le cs
il ya un autre effet qui est prévu c'est
celui de la détonation très très fort
qu'assourdissant tu comme la glnf qui a
tant fait là on a un journaliste qui a
ressenti des acouphènes et des vertiges
pendant de longues semaines et il ya un
effet qu'il n'est pas prévu c'est celui
d'un éclat vulnérant en l'occurrence
notre journaliste fabien arrive étant
bien en plein live facebook avec son
téléphone il filmer l'opération de
maintien de l'ordre
quand tout à coup les grenades ont
explosé devant lui et il a pris un éclat
au niveau de l'entrejambe qui a traversé
son pantalon de façon honnête et par
chance à l' impact l entrejambe mais
sans gravité
donc c'est une petite blessure mais il a
eu beaucoup de chance on s'en est rendu
compte ensuite en fait quand on a
analysé l'objet s'est rendu compte qu'il
s'était le même objet qui est qui avait
pénétré en fait la jambe de par le passé
d'autres manifestants et le même jour
quelques minutes avant un autre
journaliste un photographe indépendant
mohamed taha qui a déjà été reçus sur ce
plateau d'ailleurs pour en parler lui
cet objet est rentré en fait dans son
mollet et la traversée il ya en fait il
s'agit d'un bouchon en plastique les
blessures elles sont toutes aussi elles
peuvent être tout aussi grave que celle
voir on a pu voir avec les biefs 4 avec
les jets on a vu des blessures assez
graves on a vu des les mains rachel est
alors la glnf quatre mois j'ai aussi
interviewé par exemple les gens des
forces de l'ordre des syndicats des
formateurs de qui forment les policiers
au maniement des grenades pour eux ils
cette grenade est tout aussi dangereuse
voire peut-être plus parce que une
l'iaaf 4 vous n'êtes pas censés la
ramasser pour la rejeter soit au loin
sur les forces de l'ordre si votre main
explose comme disait un responsable
syndical lui le disait de façon vulgaire
c'est à dire il disait c'est bien fait
pour pour lui malheureusement c'est
effectivement un effet prévu de la
grenade aussi est potentiellement sait
qu'elle peut vous faire exploser une
main là où c'est ce qui n'est pas prévu
de l'âge m2 elle au départ c'est que des
éclats puisse voler dans tous les sens
ou a meta est sûre il est donc juchée
sur un banc dans la rue en train de
faire des photos et de filmer il ya un
trottoir en dessous donc il est à peu
près à un mètre du sol il reçoit sa dans
le mollet la de la grenade a explosé à
quelques mètres de lui à deux mètres et
100 s'il avait été au sol en fait ça
aurait pu arriver dans son ventre
antoine boitel je rappelle que vous êtes
journalistes rt france spécialisé dans
les questions policière merci pour cet
éclairage et je rappelle aussi que votre
enquête en est à retrouver en
intégralité sur notre site internet
rt france pub